So let's begin to look in more detail at some
of the aggregation operators we just touched on. Now, you
just had a quiz on this question. We're going to
look at first, the dollar match operator, and then the
dollar project operator, in the context of this question. So
the question is ,who has the highest followers to friends
ratio? The data that we're working with is from the
version 1.1 Twitter API, and here, friends means who I'm following.
So, another way of expressing this is who has
the highest followers to following ratio. Okay, so here's our
complete solution to addressing this problem using the aggregation framework.
Let's take a look at how the match operator is
used here in the first stage of the pipeline.
Now as I mentioned, match is a filtering operation, and
something that's very important to bear mind that really clears
things up I think with match, is that for match,
for the value of the match operator, you use
the same syntax that you would use for find
operations or read operations. So in this case what
we're specifying is constraints on the type of document
that we want to allow through this match stage.
What we're saying here is, I only want to
consider those who have both of friends count and
the followers count, that's greater than zero. And if
you think back to when we were talking
about queries, in the last lesson, you can
see that all we're really doing here is,
specifying a specific field in each case, and then
using an inequality operator to express a constraint
on the value for first friends count and then
followers count. And, in fact, match functions, very
similarly to find as part of the aggregation framework.